nous on va là mais ouais tu vas voir
écoute c'est une surprise toi tu fais
toujours des surprises à tout le monde
pense à toi
ça va bien
et le loup il est où il doit être au lit
qui se trouve juste à l'endroit où ils
sont en train de faire le Stade de
France et le mec c'est il a juste ce bar
qui est resté comme le dessin de santé
voilà ouais et ça c'est en bas
exactement ils vont faire le Stade de
France à l'endroit où il est en bas
exactement et toi tu veux pas partir ah
non mais lui il part pas il est juste
devant l'entrée
au festival
[Musique]
en fait une boîte de [__] pour dire
la vérité tu veux la vraie question avec
les [__] c'est de savoir si
c'est l'usage du godemichet
et en fait la ligne de fracture elle est
là
en fait c'est la seule vraie ville
nouvelle qui est autour de Paris quoi
parce que c'est tout le monde fait des
villes nouvelles depuis des années mais
ça c'est une vraie vie nouvelle quoi
puis après tu rencontres des gens qui
parlent toutes les langues
des blagues des moins blagues des
[__] tu vois et tout ça est au milieu
et tout le monde a la banane
c'est la tour de la belle mais avec de
la dance
avait une culotte mais bon reste
toujours
et on va
voir écoute c'est une surprise toi tu
fais toujours des surprises à tout le
monde
pense à toi tu étais où avant j'étais
dans une boîte de nuit la question
surprise
parce que là on va se plonger dans notre
univers de monde
viens avec moi
alors
voilà
tu vas partir du sable pour être à la
plage et ben non
alors
tu jouais au camboé aux Indiens toi non
sans arrêt ouais tu vois les rêves sont
toujours très difficiles à arriver mais
tu vas voir que petit à petit
tu vois alors ça c'est tout tu sais les
musiques de moi mais tout avec les
livres de Kobo et tout
et petit à petit
du coup voilà
[Musique]
tu vois avec les rochers
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu